Let's look at our instruction scheduling quiz solution. As is
this takes one cycle to do the load. If the load
latency was one cycle, then the add could happen the
next cycle, but because the load takes two cycles, the add
can only happen in cycle three. So, we have one
cycle three. The add takes only one cycle so the store
can proceed. Then we can do the load, it doesn't depend
on anything so we can do the load in cycle five.
The add however can now happen only in cycle seven
and finally the store happens in cycle eight. So as
is, this executes in eight cycles. The question is now
can we schedule this better to avoid some of these
stalls? And we had a stall here and here. To
avoid a stall here we need to place between the
load and the add an instruction that can be done
here without violating dependencies. We can see that this load
here doesn't depend on any of the
previous three instructions, except that we will destroy
R1 if we move that instruction here. So the correct solution to this is we will
move the load there, but we will rename
our R1 into something else. So the program
becomes now, load word R1 zero of R2 as before. Now we move the other load
there, put the result in some R10, let's say.
Now we can do this add because in the third
cycle we can do it. Now that we have done
this add we can actually do this the load has
already happened, we are now in the second cycle
since then. So the second add can happen. The add
was using R1 now we have to use R10. Next,
we will do our store and if last remaining store.
As you can see, now we have a processor where
whenever we need two cycles for the load there is
something in between the load and the use of it's
result. Here R1 is loaded, we then don't use R1 and
then we add to it. And here R10 is loaded
and then we don't do anything with R10 and then we
add to it. So this can be done in six
cycles, eliminating both of the stalled cycles that we previously had.